Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and in my Walking
Dead review I asked you to submit all of your
questions about the wtf fest that went down
as well as the next two episodes.
I picked 10 to answer in this video and one
bonus questions.
All things considered, everyone was pretty
much on the same page as far as Lizzie was
concerned.
But everyone wanted to know about what’s
coming next.
Before we get in it congratulations to this
week’s giveaway winner, Becky Green you
win the amazon gift card this week.
Everybody be sure to give her a high five.
I’ll be contacting you on your channel for
details.
Don’t worry if you didn’t win.
The next round starts Sunday and for the finale
I’m doubling down, so there will be 2 winners.
And I’ll be doing the same type of giveaway
for Game of Thrones every week too.
So that’s like 3 solid months of weekly
giveaways.
On to fun time, let’s answer some questions.
Number One comes from Decaposaurus who asks
Based on these two deaths, do you think that
there will still be another major death before
the season ends?﻿
Yes, based on all the rumors, even the ones
that aren’t super crazy.
It seems like they’re still building towards
one more death to launch things into season
5.
A lot of people are pointing fingers at Daryl
based on the teaser for the next episode.
He isn’t integrating well into the roving
band of lunatics.
And they’re making fun of the fact he can’t
find Beth.
But I think that’s just misdirection.
I’m not going to call them the Hunters until
I see human flesh go down someone’s throat.
But that doesn’t mean that once everyone
gets to Terminus, they won’t be responsible
for whoever dies next.
My earlier prediction was Maggie, just since
it fit with some of the more logical rumors.
To be honest, there is no character that I
love so badly I would freak if they died.
They’re all great, so no matter what we’re
going to feel awful.
But by all accounts, this season finale won’t
be the shit storm that the season 3 finale
was.
They’re not going to do the exact same thing.
Question 2 - kaosdevice asks Do you think
the fire was from the house Beth and Daryll
lit up?
Absolutely, and it didn’t look that far
away.
They saw it during the day, so this episode
probably took place the day after episode
12.
So while all this Lizzie business was going
down, Daryl was in the process of getting
separated from Beth.
Question 3 - Mikato Tanaka asks Do you think
that grove will be haunted with the spirits
of Lizzie and Mica from now on?﻿
I’m assuming based on your question that
you believe in ghosts.
So let’s assume they do exist and are capable
of perpetrating hauntings.
By that logic yes, they are totally haunting
the grove with that other little kid that
died before they got there.
At least there’s three of them now.
Consequently, in most horror movies ghosts
haunt places because they can’t move forward.
That means Lizzie is still crazy and Mika
is stuck with her for the rest of time.
Does that mean Mika is stuck in hell?
I’ll let you guys answer that question.
My alternate theory for what happened after
they’re going to follow Carol and Tyreese
around and give them both fever dreams until
they die too.
Question 4 - Rasengan asks When do you think
Negan will show up?
Robert Kirkman has been pretty clear that
he wanted a lot of space between The Governor
and Negan, so I think it will be at least
mid-season 5 before he becomes a recurring
character.
I am expecting some teasers in the finale.
I’m thinking that someone at Terminus might
refer to the Saviors, which is really a Negan
Teaser.
But because we haven’t met Gareth yet, it’s
pretty clear that he’ll be the big character
we’ll meet at terminus.
For better or worse.
He’s supposed to be an antagonist, but if
he’s an amalgam of Gabriel and Jesus, he’s
a good person.
Both those characters helped the survivors.
Question 5 - sandraand6690 asks why did dizzy
Lizzie kill her sister?﻿
Remember when Lizzie said I’ll change myself
and then you’ll understand.
She was talking about making Mika understand
that the Walkers were people.
She thought of them the way you would think
about your best friend.
Not a slowly moving bitey head.
So I think she thought the best way to quote
unquote, show Mika was to turn her.
Which is why she said, don’t worry.
She’ll come back, I didn’t hurt her brain.
Because hurting the brain is the only way
to kill a walker.
She was going to turn Judith to make Carol
and Tyreese understand.
Thank jeebus she did not.
Question 6 - D95 Parkour asks Since Daryl
was shown in the trailer after the episode,
do you think we will find out what happened
to Beth next week?
It seemed like almost everyone was in the
teaser BUT Beth, just based on that it seems
like they’re holding off that reveal for
the Finale.
It makes a weird kind of sense for the writers
to hang Beth over our heads for one more week.
Just making us wonder who kidnapped her, whether
or not she’s alive.
Add those things to the awfulness that looks
like it’s going to be happening anyway and
you arrive at the stress level AMC wants you
to be at.
The way I look at it is that they want everyone
in the world to watch that Finale, and the
best way to get you to do that is to hold
off on some big questions.
Namely in this case, Beth.
The big question next week is what will be
in the teaser trailer for the finale.
Question 7 - teebaby0486 asks How do you think
rick will handle seeing carol again... will
tyreese vouch for her because of the things
she had to do?
And how about Daryl if he comes back how will
he react to carol now?
Rick will mostly be happy to see Judith again,
so happy that I think he’ll forget about
the bad blood between them.
Carol wasn’t pissed when they parted ways,
so they don’t hate each other.
And even if they did, Rick is probably just
happy to find more familiar faces that survived
The Governor’s attack.
So yes, there will probably be an awkward
pause, until the camera pans to Judith and
then everyone will just break down crying
tears of joy.
Question 8 - Jamie Lannister asks Do you think
they should've left Lizzie alone with all
her "friends"?
I assume you’re talking about after she
killed Mika.
I think they didn’t just because Carol and
Tyreese still felt responsible for her.
Especially Carol.
And even if they did try to abandon her, Lizzie
would have just followed them.
I think tying her up to a tree or something
would have just been cruel.
And as much as Mika talked about not wanting
to be bad, then Carol killing Lizzie.
I don’t think Carol has ever been a bad
person.
She is a little extreme.
But remember when she confessed to Rick, she
said there was nothing she wouldn’t do for
the children.
Question 9 - Ben Goffrey (no avatar) asks
Do you think carol will eventually kill herself
with the shame of the "murders" fresh on her
hands?
In the comics she comes to the point of ending
her own life.
At this point Carol on the show is so different
from Carol in the comics that I don’t consider
them to be the same people.
There are a lot of plot points that happen
differently and psychologically I think Melissa
McBride’s version is much more in control
of herself.
She is the opposite of helpless, and sometimes
when people commit suicide, it’s because
they feel helpless.
Had she considered it, I think Tyreese’
speech about doing what they have to do, shook
her out of it.
She’ll probably start having nightmares
about them just like Tyreese has nightmares
about Karen though.
Question 10 - Kiara Ortiz asks which groups
do you think are going to be reunited first?
So in the teaser we saw Daryl, the Abraham’s
Group and Rick’s Group.
So they’re all moving toward Terminus at
about the same rate.
Glenn is the furthest behind, so I think they’ll
run into Rick’s Group first.
Most of the time the people we see in the
teasers are the only groups the episodes focus
on.
So it’s possible that Carol and Tyreese
as well as Beth, won’t show up until the
finale.
Since Daryl’s group is moving all over the
place it’s also possible he could stumble
on Abraham or Rick too.
It kind of seems like Daryl’s going to have
a tough time quitting his group.
So it might take some of the other survivors,
like Abraham, to help get rid of Joe and the
rednecks.
and one last Bonus Question - Natalie Ellis
asks do you ever think Rick will be killed
off?
This is actually a big problem for Robert
Kirkman in the comics.
There’s a big conflict going on in the comics
called All Out War.
I think that Kirkman wants to be able to safely
kill off Rick at some point without completely
enraging the fandom.
But as a temporary way to sidestep the issue,
they’ve started to feature a different group
that doesn’t include Rick.
Just to take the heat off the issue so to
speak.
So short answer, whatever happens to him,
will probably happen in the comics first.
Unless Andrew Lincoln the actor, wants off
the show.
It doesn’t always follow the comic, but
for the people alive, especially this season,
all the deaths have gone down pretty closely
to the way they happened in the comics.
So, thank you so much for submitting your
questions, this was a ton of fun.
And one more high five to Becky for winning
the giveaway this week.
A lot of you are asking me to start doing
Season 5 videos.
I’m going to do all of that stuff, but I’m
waiting till we get a little closer to the
finale.
There’s still a lot we don’t know about
how this season will end.
So I just want to wait a little bit.
Marvel Tuesday is tomorrow.
So get excited for that.
There will be new Avengers 2 footage.
Right now click here for my review of the
episode and click here for the rest of my
Season 4 predictions.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High fives!